[Music]
[Applause]
we bring in our good buddy Mark Sanchez
he was in the broadcast booth for the
Panthers and the Ravens week 11 he'll be
on the call for the Saints at the 49ers
former quarterback now analyst for Fox
Sports Mark thanks for joining us
where do you see the Niners right now if
if we did power rankings in the NFC
where do you have San Francisco
I mean they're in the top handful for
sure
um you see Jimmy G taking care of the
football and distributing the ball well
it looks like
you know there's always teams right at
the trade deadline who make this final
push
and like okay we're we're all in and
then we're gonna show you how all in we
are we're gonna go get Chris McCaffrey
we're gonna go pick up a receiver we're
gonna go pick up a tight end whatever it
takes
so clearly they're in on it and um you
know thanks for not leading me off with
uh with the jet SEC Wilson
stuff well I could have I could have led
you off with something else with the
Jets
today's the anniversary from their game
today oh come on
I didn't bring it up wins my bad oh
sorry 10 years 10 years ago 10 years ago
yeah the anniversary the fumble
you're you're better than that no I I am
I I thought you were referencing that
and I was thinking no no I I it was how
about we try this I'm actually here you
know what let's try this again three two
twenty second timeout yes Mark Sanchez
joining us uh we'll get to the Jets
coming up in a moment and we're back
okay if if but the best team in the NFC
right now is who
oh uh before last week I would have said
Minnesota you know oh really
um jeez I just thought they were playing
so so well but you could tell they had a
little bit of a hangover after that huge
win
um against Buffalo and that kind of
thing happens you know uh the year I
want to say
my second year with the Jets we went up
on Monday night we beat the Pats early
in the year it went up on Monday night
and got beat 38 to 3 or 42-3 something
ridiculous to the point where Rex
actually physically dug a hole behind
the facility and buried a game ball
meaning we're not going to talk about it
anymore we're plenty embarrassed I don't
want to see the film anymore you know
we'll go see those guys later on in the
year potentially in the playoffs and we
did in the divisional wait did you have
a ceremony where he brought the whole
team out and buried the football we
brought the whole team out buried the
ball that's how embarrassed it was like
it was that bad it was so bad I I said
it the other day
but I think that game I put Lee bottom
in the Pro Bowl I mean I threw him like
four picks or something ridiculous he
bought me he bought me a drink at that
Super Bowl actually because we were both
doing uh some event or whatever but we
were at the bar and he sends me a drink
and the bartender goes hey this is from
Lee Barton and I was like what the hell
and I see him across the bar he's like
thanks boss
you put him in the Pro Bowl with one
game
oh exactly exactly all right well let me
talk about the jet situation here and
you know when you hear Zach when you
hear Zach Wilson being asked about you
know do you apologize uh well we'll put
it in context we'll just play it here's
Zach Wilson after the loss as an offense
though I mean when you guys are only
able to score three points the defense
only lets up three points I mean do you
do you feel like you let the defense
down at all no
thank you okay
what do you do oh man
wait is that a beer
no no it's water oh okay I thought um I
I didn't want you to start drinking it
you know 10 30 in the world world cup
baby
no uh we
here's the deal
you don't
you don't ever want to let
anybody but especially in this kind of
media Market you don't want to let them
see you sweat right like
you'd like to avoid that if you can and
I know Rex sounded off on him uh I feel
like every other week I catch Strays
from rex on TV but yesterday he actually
had my back and this is something you
can't argue I can't say I was the most
talented I can't say I was the most
successful I can't
there's certain thing you know certain
performances weren't better than others
whatever
but what I can always tell you is
I fell on the sword and that's just what
you do it's part of being the position
it's more than just the X's and O's it's
who you become
when somebody walks in the room Head and
Shoulders above everybody else you're
the quarterback and people should be
able to know that that's that's just
what you sign up for the good the bad
the ugly okay
the easiest way in my opinion to handle
what he had to handle and it was a it
was a you know I'm no attorney but
not maybe badgering the witness but
leading the witness your honor like it's
a little ridiculous the question however
that question doesn't even exist if
you step up to the podium and just say
guys you know what
that was a tough one for us and we got
to get better and it starts with me
right there you just eliminate so much
but if you never say anything if you
don't acknowledge it
and you just keep going through your
press conference of course you're going
to get that question and then
you know it just looked a little
you know like he's just trying to avoid
it and he won't own it and
it's it's a big boy game now in a big
boy City and um
he's feeling I mean I mean there I
remember waking up after rough games and
just like
damn here we go you're gonna have to
step up to that Podium but at the same
time I remember running up the tunnel
after winning and after playing well and
all those things so it it all kind of
goes together and it right now it just
feels a little big for him you know what
I mean it just feels like uh like it's a
little too much and well it's really
hard I wonder because you were playing
in Los Angeles and at the time they
didn't have an NFL team so the NFL team
was USC and it felt like you were at
least accustomed to facing the media 100
I I can't uh agree with you enough and
if anybody if anybody was primed and
prepared
for this stage it would have been me
based on my experience with the media
with beat writers and interacting with
that kind of stuff
and still there was a learning curve
yeah and still out whoa you know your
words carry weight here like dang that
press conference is legit here there's a
lot going on
so if you can imagine that my kind of
learning curve from La USC Big Time
program all that and now you're going
from you know Provo to here
that's a that's a big jump so
um you know I think I think he's
experiencing that now and and
um it's difficult well Ross Tucker who
played in the NFL said yesterday that uh
Zach was Defensive you're you know
you're defensive because you may be
insecure about this if you own the team
you own the moment then act like that
and you get defensive that's not the
time to be defensive that's you go on
the offensive to say just like you did
put out the fire yes you know put out
well there's no fire there's no fire he
built a fire and then lit the match to
it yeah there there would be nothing we
would not be we would be talking about
his poor play would you start him that's
the thing they're they're gonna talk
about the if you throw five touchdowns
or throw five interceptions they gotta
report it somebody's gonna talk about it
right like it's gonna happen either way
would you start him in the next game
would you start it
the way here's what you got to ask
yourself like is he gonna give us the
best chance to win
is he putting the team at risk by
putting the football at risk
consistently and right now he's done
that in a couple of you know knucklehead
plays whatever I'm I'm okay with a
miscommunication a bad throw a really
good defensive play whatever but when if
you get too careless with the football
you're gonna make people ask like all
right is there somebody else on the
roster that can take care of the
football better than than the person
playing right now
um Can Flacco do it probably
based on the way this defense is playing
um it sounds like you know the head man
wasn't uh you know he was non-committal
about him starting
um gosh
it's so hard to say like I I can't say
benjam I just
I've been there too I got bench for Greg
McElroy like Greg and I joke about it
now at the time it was awful but first
play of the game I throw an interception
on a read that I know better like I
tried to force a ball and and
immediately Rex is like no we're not
doing that get out and it was probably
the right move you know like I
you hold the hopes and dreams and
aspirations of the entire organization
when you hold the football and if you're
going to put the football on Jeopardy
you can't play you just can't do it so
um God I can't I'm gonna go Robert saw a
noncommittal on this one I don't know uh
I'm talking to Mark Sanchez Fox NFL
analyst he has the Niners coming up
Saints at the Niners coming up this
weekend the Arizona Cardinals situation
is interesting because they signed up
everybody long term coach GM uh
quarterback
and it just feels like there's something
that's missing there that is not going
to be good here by the end of the season
what do you think yeah and I I don't I
don't think guys miked up and being able
to watch the conversations on the
sidelines on like a Wednesday have
really helped that situation sorry I
keep getting a phone call
um I
it sounds like something's off it looks
like there's communication issues but
once again I'm not in that locker room
you could just tell by by the way it's
going down
um you know I thought Coldplay alright
he came in and try to do his job last
night but it's
you know they were built for Kyler to
play and
um you know you start asking yourself
questions about everything going on the
whole clause and the contract like all
that stuff starts to come up again you
know when it when it doesn't go right
and
but why no receivers talk about you know
when you have a quarterback in the
pocket you can run your routes you sort
of know there's timing and all of that
with Kyler Lamar when these guys are
going to be running and and you know I
think it's harder for these receivers so
they probably look at somebody like
Jimmy Garoppolo or Colt McCoy you kind
of know where the quarterback's going to
be and helps you do your job a little
bit more is that a fair assessment of
these quarters I'd say that's fair I'd
say you know
generally speaking more of a pocket
passer like the coordinator or the
quarterback coach the receiver coach
when the ball snapped or right before a
pretty good idea based on what you're
seeing like okay the ball's either gonna
go here here or here or oh boy I hope we
make a good decision here because this
doesn't look good
um when you get guys who have that
special ability to extend plays
you have to be Nails on your scramble
rules meaning okay this is the play this
is the original play but as soon as he
breaks contain as soon as you know
something goes
different than what we planned boom this
is our new plant this is our contingency
plan yeah when he goes this way I need
someone shallow I need someone trailing
if you're deep stay deep if you're close
to the quarterback find a window and get
in Phase with him so I can you know find
a lane and find you
it just looks off something looks off
and they're not all on the same page
um
and uh yeah it's really showing on the
field
Caleb Williams reminds you of who
he's got a little more homes to him uh I
keep hearing that a little yeah yeah
it's I I think some of it's like the arm
angle and the the
um innate like god-given Talent with his
arm it's it's special and
he'll extend plays sometimes he'll like
drop back and then it almost looks like
the old um
um
gosh it was it we used to call it like a
Sprint and basically you'd you'd drop
back three steps to kind of get the
defense to to bite and and get the pass
rush to bite and then you'd kind of boot
out to your left or right but you'd have
to set them for a second almost like
setting the hook and fishing kind of
deal like you wait and boom set the hook
well Caleb can drop back and then kind
of drops back again a couple times in
the game he'll just like move to the
right like six steps and then just
re-establish his base and look around
I'm like whoa what's he doing you know
how's how's he doing that a lot of guys
can't reassess right like as soon as you
break the pocket and everything changes
the picture changes
he's out of it re-establishes himself
and has this ability to
to find everybody again it's that's
really hard to do and he does it with
ease
um you know I thought the only issue in
that game the other day is just at the
end of the game you know you can't take
that sack right like keep your team down
there get the field goal but you know
they they overcome it and win the game
so it doesn't matter but
um he's he's one of the best in the
country hands down and he looks like
he's having fun
um and in an offense like that you know
you get to air it out like crazy it's
really fun to watch how much do you hate
Notre Dame
um I don't know if I ever like hated
them uh I'll tell you what I did hate we
used to stay at that crappy hotel when
you go on the road and the whole thing
you know like those indoor pools
and the whole thing smells like chlorine
and like it just kind of hurts to
breathe in there like it was terrible I
used to hate going to wherever we had to
go
um but I do remember you know my um my
recruiting visit there and they said you
know you got to live on campus for three
years and all this stuff and you know
coming from Southern California
the town was you know as big as our high
school I was like what the heck is going
on out here you know this is this is
different I don't know I don't know if
it's gonna work for the kid here
who was the quarterback though you would
have competed with at Notre Dame
at Notre Dame Brady Quinn was there
um I don't know if they ended up taking
anybody in the same class
Colt ended up going to Texas I tripped
to Texas Ohio State Notre Dame
um
Mack Brown was one of the best I mean
we're talking used car salesman now he
was awesome he sold Texas so hard and I
was you know I had no reason they're
taking a kid named Colt McCoy who lived
up the street okay my dad's like are you
kidding me you got no [ __ ] named Sanchez
it's a Mexican kid from California like
are you nuts the kid's name is Colt
McCoy like no no chance it should have
been cold Cold Austin you know exactly
Austin McCoy would have fit uh that's
pretty Jimmy Claussen probably was there
wasn't he oh uh no he was after me
though oh exactly okay
getting too old man yeah hey uh safe
travels there up to uh San Francisco
that's not a well you're in New York now
then you got to go back and then go up
go back home do a little Thanksgiving
celebration
um you know it used to be my favorite
holiday until you bring up uh
anniversary you know
I I seriously thought you were bringing
up the anniversary because you were
gonna get out in front of it you were
going to be the anti-sac there we go you
were gonna bring it all together you
were gonna bring it up and and you were
going to mention that it's the 10-year
anniversary of the bud phone put out the
fire that's it that's my bad man I've
read the room wrong I I pulled a Zach
Wilson I I'm gonna take ownership that
was that was really the knock on you
coming out in the draft you know just
reading the room
uh great to talk to you as always
you guys are awesome thank you buddy
yeah good sport Mark Sanchez we had some
funny lines in there